c'était notre collègue madame christiane
kammermann pour le groupe l'est
républicain et pour deux minutes
vous avez la parole merci monsieur le
président monsieur le président mesdames
et messieurs les ministres mes chers
collègues ma question s'adresse à
monsieur milices des affaires étrangères
et du développement international
la situation à l'ep est dramatique hier
des tirs de missiles ont tué près de 50
civils dont des enfants et ont fait de
nombreux blessés dans des établissements
médicaux et des écoles entre 50000 et
soixante dix mille personnes ont fui les
violents conflits dans la région d'alep
35 mille civils se retrouvent bloqués à
la frontière turque sans pouvoir la
franchir et 350 millions se trouvent
piégés dans la ville
cent soixante mille personnes ont été
obligées de fuir les violents combats au
nord comme au sud du pays
ces populations vivent l'horreur elles
ont besoin d'une aide d'urgence incluant
des distributions alimentaires les
produits de première nécessité il est
très difficile pour l'aide humanitaire
d'accéder à certaines zones
car la route reliant la ville d'alep au
nord de la syrie a été coupée monsieur
le ministre la voix de la france est
bien faible sur ces sujets quelle mesure
envisagez vous de prendre pour que notre
pays pèse sur le plan diplomatique
quelles initiatives envisagez vous de
prendre pour que l'aide humanitaire
tentateur attendu interviennent
allez-vous infléchir les choix de votre
prédécesseur pour vous répondre
la parole est à monsieur jean marc
ayrault mais les affaires étrangères du
développement international
merci monsieur le président mesdames
messieurs les sénateurs madame la
sénatrice
vous n'avez pas du tout exagéré dans la
description de la situation dramatique
que vivent les populations de ces deux
de l'as de syrie aujourd'hui vous avez
même évoqué le drame qui a touché à un
hôpital géré par des volontaires de
médecins sans frontières qui a reçu des
bombes une première fois et
ceux qui tiraient je pense que vous les
avez identifiés ont récidivé
parce qu'il y avait là une cible et ce
n'était pas la première fois que des
objectifs médicaux étaient visés donc la
situation est dramatique et l'urgence à
l'urgence humanitaire est la priorité
mais aujourd'hui nous sommes dans
l'incapacité d'intervenir pour aider à
ces populations halep 6 1 millions
d'habitants ces cinquante mille
personnes qui tentent de fuir qu'ils ne
peuvent pas donc je crois qu'aujourd'hui
il faut être d'une très grande exigence
est d'une très grande fermeté à l'égard
de toutes les parties qui interviennent
militairement et des engagements étaient
pris à munich le 11 février dernier qui
sont très claires stopper les hosties
arrêter les hostilités stopper les
bombardements et cette demande de
stopper les bombardements laquelle est
associée la france concerne tout le
monde
tout le monde doit arrêter le bombarder
sans hypocrisie je le dis ici et c'est
essentiel parce que si on veut
intervenir
et là il ya un délai d'une semaine qui a
été fixée alors il faut que ces attaques
cessent parce que nous sommes incapables
de le faire donc nous le ferons et cela
s'inscrit dans une volonté globale de
solution politique à ce conflit car vous
l'avez évoqué ya la solution militaire
mais elle ne peut pas être exclusive
c'est pour ça que si les bombardements
cessent l'aide humanitaire va intervenir
mais en plus nous allons reprendre les
discussions à genève sous l'égide des
nations unies
le plus vite possible une d'apt à
d'ailleurs été fixée le 25 février
prochain
tout ça est urgent tout ça est notre
combat commun je crois que nous pouvons
grâce nous rassembler sur cet objectif
et puis en même temps tout faire pour
que l'essentiel de la lutte soient
concentrées contre des échelles
terrorisme
merci monsieur me dit madame caméraman
vous voulez sur 35 secondes ajouté
quelque chose
alors monsieur le ministre notre
politique étrangère est de moins en
moins lisible sur la scène
internationale cette illisibilité
conduit malheureusement à l'impuissance
vous venez d'en parler actuellement on a
le sentiment que la france
ne porte plus une voix originale et sa
politique étrangère donne le sentiment
de celle de s'aligner à celle des états
unis alors qu'elle aurait pu et dû avoir
un rôle singulier en gardant son
indépendance si je suis un collègue